et pour la fin de ce journal c'est
mélanie poquet qui m'a rejoint un
plateau bonsoir ça au musée de la ville
de saint quentin en yvelines on vous
emmène à travers l'histoire grâce aux
objets pour sa nouvelle exposition le
site parle des objets de notre temps et
c'est votre coup de coeur culture de la
semaine mélanie pas moins de 90 objets
sont rassemblés au coeur du musée au
sein de son exposition temporaire
une plongée au coeur du xxème siècle
l'exposition débute plutôt dans les
années 30 mais il ya surtout un gros
focus dans les années 60 70 avec grégory
cette époque où les objets pullulent les
trente glorieuses c'est l'arrivée
massive de la publicité création
d'objets nouveau mais aussi de nouveaux
métiers
durant ces années le designer imagine
toutes sortes d'objets au fond nous
original voire improbables et surtout
c'est une explosion de couleurs et c'est
une exposition qui est pensé de façon
thématique
oui alors elles sont au nombre de quatre
ces thématiques qui lie à la cuisine et
l'hygiène des nouvelles technologies qui
concerne principalement le salon vous
pourrez notamment voir l'évolution des
postes de télévision et la 4e thématique
c'est le confort là il sera plutôt
question des fauteuils et des sièges et
en cette époque où on consomme beaucoup
mélanie c'est une exposition qui peut
faire réfléchir
et oui pourquoi pas l'exposition apporte
aussi un regard critique sur la société
de consommation à travers un regard
plutôt originale des chansons populaires
de l'époque interprété entre autres par
gilbert bécaud et serge gainsbourg alors
l'exposition débute dès demain mercredi
17 avril et vous avez jusqu'au 27
juillet pour découvrir tous ces objets
et peut-être vous rendre compte que dans
votre grenier grenier de se cacher
pépites comme vous en aurez au musée de
la ville merci mélanie pour cette
chronique et vous prendrez ma place dans
quelques instants à la présentation du
7-8 culture un retour notamment sur l'
incendie de notre dame de paris et les
réactions sur le monde culturel du monde
culturel yvelinois qui seront à suivre
d'en haut dans votre émission